[Müzik]
baylar bayanlar hanımefendiler
beyefendiler
dinamik gençler sevgili çocuklar Hepiniz
hoş geldiniz
sevgili Emrah duruşuyla dedi Öncelikle
duruşu bir yapayım
Doğru kişiyi
izlediğinizde emin olun o kadar fazla
yanıltıcı o kadar fazla gerçekliğin
karıştığı bir dünya içerisindeyiz ki o
yüzden de mümkün olduğunca eşlerini
giyinmeye eşlenik durmaya bunun gerçek
bir insan olduğunu anlatmaya çalışıyorum
bulunduğum her yerde belki tarihin en
kısa tedx konuşmasına şahit olacaksınız
şu anda Ama amacına da ulaşsın Madem
buradasınız Madem bilgi vermeye
çalışıyoruz anılarımızı paylaşıyoruz ben
soracağım Siz sadece düşüneceksiniz ve
süreyi bu şekilde uzatacağız Bakalım 18
dakika içerisinde 20 dakika içerisinde
bitirebilecek misiniz soruyorum
paranın hiç olmadığı ya da hiç
konuşulmadı bir dönemi hayal edin lütfen
beni dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim
zor değil mi
şimdi hazineler konuşuyoruz insan
konuşuyoruz insanın da bu süreci
içerisinde önce bir kendine bakması
lazım bu süreçte ben ne yaptım ne ettim
o yüzden de madem konumuz hazine hazine
ile ilgili de şu anda kültür
miraslarımız var duamız var Farklı
farklı birçok konumuz var ama insanın en
temelinde aklına gelen
[Müzik]
duygusal kısımsın değil mi bu sürecin
içerisinde Biz kendimiz O parayla o
hazine yapılarıyla ya da define
dediğimiz kurallarla birlikte Nasıl
tanıştık nasıl yaşadık Öncelikle ben
kendime bunu sordum ve benim parayla
tanışma hikayemde sizinle paylaşmak
istiyorum ardından
[Müzik]
örneklemelerle devam edeceğiz
parayı verirler ufaklıklara ve Derler ki
git şuradan işte ekmek al git şuradan
süt al git şuradan kendine sakız al Bana
da benzer şekilde küçükken vermişlerdi
o parayı aldım ve Dediler ki bana
şuradan ekmek getir bu benim görevim
gittim
tezgahlarımız var biliyorsunuz boyumuz
da kısa
tezgah şurada diyelim Ben oranın neresi
olduğunu görmüyorum Elimdeki ne olduğunu
da bilmediğim Bir nesneyi karşı tarafa
uzattım ve dedim bana bir ekmek verir
misiniz
şöyle uzandı
Baktı ki ilk defa alışveriş yapmaya
geliyor şöyle başımı okşadı ve dedi ki
sevgili arkadaşım burası Kasap
ne yapmam lazım bilmiyorum Çünkü bana
tek komut verilmiş Elimde bir nesne
sonra para olduğunu anlayacağım ve onu
götürüp bir kişiye verip ondan da bir
hizmet ürün ya da servis almak
parayla tanışmam bu şekilde başladı
Sonra ben şunları farkettim ki
sap varmış manav varmış Bakkal varmış ve
bunların da böyle ücretsiz olduğu bir
dönem yok o yüzden ne yapmam gerek bu
mekanizmayı anlamam gerek çok meraklı
bir çocuktum her zaman bu merakım bana
her yerde fayda sağladı ve özellikle de
paranın kazanılmasıyla ilgili kendime
bir sistem geliştirmeliyim Ben yaş 5-0
düzeydeyim bunu her çıktığım söyleşide
Seminerde konferansda özellikle dile
getirmeye çalışıyorum Çünkü her yaşın
kendi dönemi içerisinde
gerçeklikleri var ve bu gerçeklikleri
yaşıyorsunuz Bunlar öğretilmiş gerçeklik
olabilir sizin keşfettikleriniz olabilir
ama tamamen bu sürecin içerisinde o
o dönemin size ait olan geçmişini de
oluşturur hale geliyor Yani ben yaş 5-0
diyorum Niye Çünkü teknolojik görünmem
lazım Çünkü anonsor o şekilde yapılıyor
yani Sanayi 3-0 işte endüstri 4-0
5g'ler 6g'ler bunların konuşulduğu bir
yerde de yaşamımızı da niye rakamlarla
söylemeyelim içerisinde de onar senelik
5 5'er senelik 10 dönem görmüş
oluyorsunuz yani Özellikle bizim nesil
için çok büyük avantajları var Zira biz
teknolojinin olmadığı bir dönemle
teknolojinin en ileri olmaya çalıştığı
dönem arasında bir geçiş süreci
yaşıyoruz dönelim bizim para hikayemize
Ben bir televizyon çocuğu olarak dünyaya
geldim televizyonu Türkiye'de ilk
kurulma süreçleri içerisinde anne baba
Orada tanışıyorlar ve ben onların bir
aşk meyvesi olarak dünyaya geldim peki
para bulmak için ne yapmam lazım hayatım
TRT'nin içerisindeki tozlu koridorlarda
geçiyor ve en çok gördüğüm sanatçı
arkadaşlar
onlardan ya işte sinema sektörü ya da
şarkı dedim ki şarkı kolay ya ben
yaparım bu arada da TRT çocuk korosu var
TRT Çocuk korosuna girdiğim zaman şunu
düşünüyorum oraya girdiğim zaman büyük
ihtimalle bana para verecekler ver ben
oradan aralarından sıyrılırsam çıkacağım
ciddi anlamda meşhur olacağım paraya
para demeyeceğim
o dönemin çocuk şarkılarından bir tanesi
Horozumu Kaçırdılar büyük ihtimalle
bilmiyorsunuz O Kadar eski
bana öğretiyorlar diyor ki bakacaksın
sahne var işte orada bir kurul var
kurulun önünde şarkıyı söyleyeceksin
tamam sözlerini dedim işte Horozumu
kaçırdılar damdan dama uçurdular suyuna
da pilav pişirdiler
benim güzel horozum tamam mı Tamam
5 yaşıma dönüyorum
geldim
[Müzik]
Sevgili Devrim hoş geldin merhaba
şarkın var mı Var tabii ki bize söyler
misin elbette
şu anki kıyafetli 5 yaşına düşünün ve
başladım ben
horozumu Amanın kaçırdılar damdan dama
uçurdular suyuna da pilav dediler ki
teşekkür ederiz Tabii ki bitti bu iş
emin olarak kendini dışarı çıktım
Ne oldu dediler çünkü erken bitti
çok beğendi yani gerek görmediler
sonrasında
İşte o anda Türkiye çok büyük bir ses
sanatçısı'nı kaybetti
hazinelerden bir tanesi
kayboldu ama bir
bilgi işlemci bir gelecek
sevdallısı ve bir konuşmacı kazanmış
oldu
[Müzik]
O yüzden de konuşmamak içerisinde bazen
şarkı söylersem nedeni budur sahnelere
çıkabiliyor O yüzden ben de konuşma
süreçlerimi içerisinde aralara yedirmeye
çalışıyorum şimdi dediğim gibi konumuz
Hazine ve hazinelerin içerisinde de
Geçmişini bilmeyen geleceğine
şekillendiremez ya da yönetemez ve biz
ne yazık ki kendi günlük hayat
gayelerimizi içerisinde bunları Çok
fazla düşünmediğimiz ya da akla
getirmediğim için ne yazık ki bize
öğretilmiş gerçeklikleri yaşıyoruz ve o
gerçekliklerin içerisinde de
geleceğimizi geçmişten aldığımız
bilgilerle şekillendirmek yerine kendisi
içerisinde O çok fazla çaba sarf etmeden
eskiyi Bilmeden bir gelecek yaratmaya
çalışıyorsun işte Bununla ilgili
esasında geçmişten günümüze gelene kadar
da çok fazla
mirasımız var şarkılarımız var
filmlerimiz var
en basiti
para para para para para para para
varlığı bir dert yokluğu yara
alkış almadığıma göre demek ki gene
müzikle bir arama olmayacak hiçbir zaman
Çok naziksiniz Çok teşekkür ederim O
jüri geldi gözlerimin önüne
hayatımızda para sürecinin içerisine
baktığımızda ki ilk dönemi yine size bir
hikayeleştirilmiş şekilde
senaryalaştırarak canlandırmak isterim
dedik ya her dönemin kendi hazinesi
değeri ya da o Emek süreci farklı bizim
hazine olarak gördüğümüz şeyler niye
genelde para olarak fark ediliyor ya da
niye insanların şemasında böyle bir kasa
içerisinde çilçil altınlar işte değerli
mücevherler hiç düşündünüz mü
paranın değil mi sormuş oldum soruya
geri dönecek olursak hiç olmadı bir
dönem var o da önemli içerisinde
var mısınız beraber gidelim mi Ama o
döneme gidebilmek için sadece yaprakla
kalmak lazım yani gerçek hazinelerin
olduğu dünyaya gelebilir misiniz
O yüzden de geçmişe gitmek çok kolay
değil yaprakla kalmak çok kolay değil
Ben sizin adınıza gidiyorum Hazır
mısınız
şimdi
arka planda baktığımız zaman bir dönem
var Birisi elinde mızrakla mamut peşinde
koşuyor mamutun ne olduğunu bilmeyenler
için filden biraz daha iri bir canlı bir
hayvan onu avladığınız zaman o bölgenin
bir aylık et ihtiyacı bitmiş oluyor kimi
bununla karnını doyurmaya çalışıyor
çünkü ana amaç karın doyurmak Yani Bunun
haricinde başka bir şey yok Mühim olan
akşam kafayı yasta
Kaya'ya koyduğunuzda Sabah kalktığınızda
tekrar o enerjiyi toplayabilmek için o
hayvanlarla birlikte
Hayatınızı devam ettirebilmek için
onları avlıyor olmak bir kesin bununla
hayatına devam ederken bir kesin bakıyor
ki bir deniz var
içerisinde bir şeyler hoplayıp zıplıyor
Aa diyorlar oradan büyük ihtimalle
Balıkçılık başlıyor bir kesin var Toprak
var
toprağın Üzerine güneş yansıyor sonra
yağmur güneş yağmur güneş yağmur bir
şeye bakıyorlar ki Aa orada Doğa bize
bir şeyler veriyor bir şeyler
filizlenmeye başlıyor
ardından
bir kesimde fark ediyor ki dünya
üzerinde
yaşayan bir tek canlı biz değiliz
meleyenler var möleyenler var onları
fark ediyorlar ve böylelikle Biz de
hayvancılık tarım ve Balıkçılık yani
denizden aldığımız mahsuller başlamış
oluyor Lütfen dikkat edin şu ana kadar
herkes mutlu hiç kimsenin derdi tasası
yok Ve herkesin hazinesi O ana kadar
karnını doyurmakla ilgili İnsanların en
temel ihtiyacı peki
sürekli hep aynı şeyi yiyorsunuz et
yiyenler balık yiyenler hepsi Her gün
aynı şeyi yiyor büyük ihtimalle birileri
diyor ki ya et yiyen arkadaşlar ot diyen
Arkadaşlar şu da bir şeyler tutuyor
gelin ona bir bakalım gidiyorlar denizin
kenarına ve orada balıkçılar ki
arkadaş sen işte irili ufaklı lüferi
kefali hamsisi o dönemde de vardır diye
tahmin ediyorum bunları tutuyorsun
yiyorsun ancak biz bunları ne olduğunu
bilmiyoruz
O da diyor ki dükkan size Yani bütün
Okyanus işte denizler hepsi sizin
buyurun
daha para Keşfedilmemiş O yüzden
dükkansın ve sürekli değişim başlıyor
büyük ihtimalle İşte o et yiyenler ot
yiyenlere ot yiyenler balık yiyenlere
balık yiyenler süt süt yumurta Mısır her
şey böyle değişir hale geliyor ta ki
İhtiyaç fazlalaşmaya ve o ekosistemi
içerisindeki denizin ya da doğanın ya da
hayvanların sizi memnun etme yetisi ya
da
soğuk almayana kadar işte o anda
karşımıza çıkan mantıkta bizim değer
yargılarımızı oluşturmaya başlıyor ve bu
değer yargılarımız karşısında da artık
et ve o türetenler ya da bununla
beslenenler Balıkçıya gittiklerinde
dükkan senin ben farklı bir cevap almaya
başlıyorlar o cevapta artık bunu bir
emek karşılığında onlara verileceğini
söyleniyor olması Peki bu Emek ne
birazcık da ona irdeleyecek olursak
bizim hayatımızda hazine olarak
elde ettiğimiz değerlere
ulaşabilmemizin en temel prensibi Emek
harcamak Peki bu emeği nasıl harcıyoruz
genelde de Prensip olarak o emeği alanı
teriyle harcıyorduk bugüne kadar peki o
dönemden sonra gelen sistemlerde Lütfen
dikkat edin alın terini günümüze gelene
kadar ki süreçlerde
sanayiyle endüstri ile ya da son
dönemlerin teknolojik dijitalleşme
süreçleriyle birlikte Yavaş yavaş
makinelere devretmeye başladık bütün bu
ekosistemin içerisinde o Emek oradan
çıkararak Yani insanın kendi elinden
çıkararak tamamen makinelere devrolmaya
başladı Keşke böyle kalsaydı Keşke
buraya kadar kalsaydı ancak
farklı
yapımızı daha devretmeye başladık O da
aklımız
akıllı telefonlar akıllı saatler akıllı
cihazlar akıllı onlar akıllı Bunlar ve o
andan itibaren de bizim bu dünya
üzerinde üretmek için hazineye ulaşım
sistemlerimizde değişmeye başladı Yani
artık o değere ulaşabilmek için o emeği
sarf etmektense o emeği Eskiden tüm
vücudumuzla işte elimizdeki cihazlarla
birlikte Efor sarf ederek fiziksel
olarak kazanmaya elde etmeye çalışırken
artık bu eforu
parmağımızın ucuna getirmeye başladık Ve
bugün siz Herhangi bir ihtiyacınız
dahilinde
gak deyince su guk deyince et
Bütün bunların hepsini oturdunuz yerden
yapmaya başlarsanız artık o hazine
kavramı da değişmeye başladı
ve bütün bu kavramların
günümüzdeki geçmiş dönemle yeni dönemin
birleştirdiği bir gelenek görenek
Değişimi de var Eskiden Bütün bunların
hepsini biz fiziksel olarak çok yakın
bir dönemde Bayram geçirdik Bayram
öncesinde gider güzel güzel kıyafetler
ayakkabılar alır onlar bayrama kadar
giyilmez ve o dönemin içerisinde o
bayram günü
bu şekilde bayramlığı bir keyfine
çıkarırdık ama yeni nesil
Avatar adını vermiş olduğumuz tamamen bu
yeni dünyalar yeni Evrenler üzerinde
bunu gerçekleştirmeye çalışır hale
geliyorlar ve özellikle de bugün buradan
dediğimizde herkes
metafizikten yola çıkarak geleceğin ya
da farklı bir dönemin ya da öte
dünyaların tanımı olarak değerlendiriyor
ama ben bugün birazcık açıyı
değiştirerek size farklı bir Odak sunmak
isterim O da bizim geçmiş dönemden
günümüze gelene kadar ki konvansiyonel
dünyada oluşturmuş olduğumuz bütün
parçacık yapılarını eğer biz dijitalize
edebilirsek ve bu dijitalize etmiş
olduğumuz parçacıkları günün normlarında
gelecek nesillere ona herhangi bir
Alınteri bırakmadan herhangi bir eve
harcaması bırakmadan
onların bu şekilde gelişeceğini ve bu
şekilde zengin olacağını hazine
bulacağını anlatırsak onlar da ona doğru
biliyorlar ve lütfen gene şapkayı
önümüze koyup bir düşünmekte fayda var
Zira bugün tüm bebekler dahil olmak
üzere tüm çocuklarımızı ve gençlerimizin
özellikle ekran bağımlılığının olmasının
temel nedenlerinden başlıcası da biziz
niye derseniz Çünkü bizim onlarla
kaliteli geçirmiş olduğumuz vakit artık
daha azalmaya başladı Zira gün
içerisinde Biz de bize birikmiş olan
mesajlar bize gelmiş olan talepler ya da
ister beyaz yaka olun ister Mavi Yaka
olun isterseniz serbest meslek sahibi
olun Bütün bunların hepsini o gün
içerisinde halletmek gerekiyor Peki
nerede bunun emeği nerede bunun değil
bunların gene bir şarkıyla özetini
vermek gerekirse
Bu Dünya Ne Sana Kalır Ne Bana
Sultan Süleyman'a kalmadı Hiçbir kitap
yazmaz diyor şarkı temele niye
Çünkü temelinde Bu Dünyanın Üzerinde
konvansiyon olarak herhangi bir şeyi biz
artık emek sarf etmeden elde etmeye
çalışıyoruz ve hazine dediğimiz O büyük
kasaların içerisindeki altınlar Gümüşler
ya da oradaki ışıltılı Madenler Bizim
hayatımızda çok fazla seyretmiyor Niye
artık onların yapabilitesinden daha çok
dijital taraf ve bugün Bütün bunların da
geçmiş atasözlerimizle birlikte Ee
özdeşleştirmeye eşleştirmeye çalışıyoruz
ve Diyoruz ki işte yeni dönemin
petrolü verilir
her dönemde olduğu gibi petrolün de para
yerine geçti dönemler var Bununla ilgili
şarkımız yok mu
Aman Petrol Canım Petrol artık sana sana
Sana Muhtacım Petrol
altında sonra gümüş oldu
o dönem petroldü
şimdi
farklı dijital paralar farklı sistemler
farklı bakış açıları artık nasıl emeği
değer yapısının dışında farklı
şekillerde işitir hale geliyorsa artık
günümüzde de onlara ulaşabilmek için çok
böyle konvansiyonel sistemlere ya da
konvansiyonel nesnelere ihtiyacımız yok
temel olarak dijital a ile b arasında
ilişki kurabilecek her türlü şeyi Biz
temas edir temas edebilir bir veri
halinde sunuyorsak bizim hayatımızda her
şey yoluna girmeye başlıyor
işte O andan itibaren de bizim hazine
kavramımız nasıl insan bazında
değişiyorsa artık o insanlıkta yerden
yurttan ya da zamanda bağımsız hale de
gelmeye başlıyor bunun temelinde ne var
bunun temelinde de artık
globalleşme bizim en önemli Odak
noktalarımızdan birisi olmak zorunda
Zira
bu sene hep söylüyorum Cumhuriyetimizin
100 senesini kutlayacağız hep beraber ve
bu Cumhuriyetimizin 100 senesi
içerisinde oluşturmuş olduğumuz mantık
artık bizim sınırlarımızın dışına çıkmak
zorunda Zira bugün baktığımızda toplamda
50 milyon kullanıcıya ulaşmış tekil
yegane nasıl kafanızda canlanırsa bir
şirketimiz yok buna bu şekilde hizmet
veren servis veren ya da ürün sağlayan
herhangi bir şirketimiz Yok nedeni de
çok basit matematiksel çok uzaklara
gitmeye gerek yok
85 milyonluk bir nüfus içerisinde 50
milyona hitap edebilecek bir hizmet ürün
ya da servis sağlamak için %60-65
civarında bir değer üretmelisiniz o
değeri artık dediğim gibi emekle
üretemediğimiz için onu da ne yazık ki
yavaş yavaş
farklılaşmaya ya da globalleşme yönünde
değer olarak benimsemeye başladı
gelmemiz lazım 85 milyona değildi 850
milyona hitap edersek 10 katına
çıkartırız o zaman
rakamlar da artmaya başlar buna 100
katına çıkartır da tüm dünya nüfusu
hitap eder hale getirirsek de toplamda 8
milyara gelmiş olacağız
insanlar konuşa konuşa robotlar kodlaşa
kodlaşa O yüzden de özellikle büyük
küçük demeden benden geldi artık benim
için değil demeden Sizden ricam
insanlarla nasıl konuşuyorsanız
makinalarla da robotlarla da kodlaşmayı
öğrenir hale gelmemiz şart bunu yapmaya
çalışan özellikle gençlerimizi Ve
ufaklıkları daha fazla bilinçlendirmeli
ve onları destek olmalıyız buradan tüm
ebeveynlerimize de onları birazcık da
olsa oyun saatlerini ya da ekran başında
geçirdiği süreleri izin olarak Sizden
rica ediyorum bir abileri olarak beni
dinlediğiniz için çok teşekkür ederim
efendim Sağ olun
[Müzik]